Add another stream to the leader boy.
Bless one, bless one.
I'm so tired.
At this one stream, we're off on time.
I'm awake.
I'm awake, everyone.
Not mentally awake, but my physical, disgusting body is
here.
Wait, she's losing...
Plus one on the leader point.
I'm catching up, everyone.
I'm catching up.
I took the nap, gotcha.
I didn't work out.
I touched grass in the morning.
I was like, it'll be fine.
I'm going to take a little nap.
I'm going to have one more.
It's going to be all right.
I'm going to wake up in...
I woke up in time, but I was going to be all right.
I'm going to be all right.
Fiction.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for fucking...
Oh, my God.
I'm waking up right now.
I woke up at, like, I think, like, 5.50.
I was like, whoa!
I was just like, whoa!
I can't...
I have...
I had to get on the leader point.
I can't close my eyes.
I gotta get on the leader point.
I can't prove them right.
I gotta prove that out of pure fucking spite.
I gotta prove everyone wrong.
I gotta climb the rankings, you guys.
Now it's serious.
Now it's competitive.
The VTuber Elo.
Anyway, fiction, just so you know, I consider you my best
girlfriend, not romantically, you're my best friend who's
also a girl, I don't know where I'll be without you.
You're my rate of sunshine, then you'll be super chat, thank
you, thank you, now it's ranked, I'm locked in now, um, oh,
fuck, oh, I was gonna talk about, my mind's all over the
place right now, um, you guys, okay, life update, not my
life but general life did you guys hear about the you guys
know the disney con d23 the big disney convention where they
announced everything did you guys hear that do you think you
prepare it was powerpoint the speed run you're yapping thank
you for the super chat freedom thank you thank you so for
those who don't know uh d23 is like the biggest event in the
world where they just announce everything they just announce
all the things that needs to be announced to hype people up
with the multi uh corporation conglomerate capitalistic
company that rules the world i forget i don't know i can't
guys i i'm a brain's not awake right now to make jokes it's
just real it's just real life I just I'm just describing
Disney right now there's nothing funny about it that's all
real
it's okay so um anyway uh yeah so in one of the
announcements I thought it was great is that they announced
Kingdom Hearts 4 like well I mean we all know Kingdom Hearts
4 like they just They're like, oh my gosh, we were Kingdom
Hearts 4?
Kingdom, oh, I don't know what else to say.
We all know Kingdom Hearts 4 was coming, but we finally got
our first world reveal and it was Coco.
I thought it was really funny, the lead up, the lead up to
the precursor to announcing Kingdom Hearts 4, like Coco
being in Kingdom Hearts 4, is that they're making a sequel
to Coco and I thought I was just like I thought it was so
funny because I was just like do we really need a sequel to
Coco The grandma's dead like See I mean we all knew the
grandma was gonna die she was so fucking old but like Then
they're like oh now the grandma's dead and Coco too I was
like yeah, we know she was going to die.
She was barely like she was she could barely remember shit
like like yeah oh sorry i just realized i'm on that was on
my recording setting i had to record some stuff um yeah yeah
we all yeah we all yeah she oh yeah she did oh we had the
end of the movie they were like she passed away and now in
the second movie they're like oh he's he's older now um
should be back now i had to swap the my settings so yeah i
sounded quiet earlier because i forgot i was on the wrong i
was on the wrong settings um yeah so so i guess like coco
too like the premise was just the fact that like uh i don't
remember what's his name again i call him coco is his name
coco it's i didn't even realize when did coco okay coco is a
beautiful movie by the way it's a beautiful movie and i felt
like it should have just been a standalone movie like did
not have to go through a sequel slap like every other
fucking movie by the way they also announced the live action
leel and stitch 2 movie too i was like we did not need that
like the live action i have miguel i call him john coco um
oh it's been 2017 yeah it should have been a standalone
movie but you know you know disney and sequel slap this like
remember coco what do we make go go again a beautiful movie
i i cried watching coco every time i uh hear the song
remember me um i actually tear up every time remember me
that song i always tear up every time i hear like watch the
song where he sings it to sings it to his grandma's but we
definitely did not need coco too I yeah we definitely did
not need that and then okay so Coco 2 is mean it got
announced as the sequel and then um what's his name what's
John Coco's name Miguel right Miguel um he's like older now
I love the memes about this like we all had him like all the
uh uh all the uh Latinos and Tina's were like, we all have a
Miguel in our lives.
We all have a cousin that looks like Miguel.
So for those who don't know, this is what Miguel looks like
right now.
Or not now, but in two years as a teenager.
This is him right now.
And everyone's just like, oh, we all know a Miguel.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
As Latina, I'm glad that Coco's This movie actually made me
cry, because that really was for me.
Thank me, Super Chat, thank you.
Yeah, Coco made me cry too.
I really enjoyed the movie.
I just didn't think it deserved.
Like, I don't say deserve, not deserved, but I didn't think
it needed a sequel, I think it ended on for a really, really
good note.
And there was no reason to...
There was no reason to make a second one, because it's just
a really good standalone film.
Yeah, as a Hispanic can confirm.
yes i i just love the tweets or like like the spanish are
like everyone has a cousin that looks like miguel uh also
don't think i didn't see your fucking uh message earlier
thinking that wasn't i was gonna be late don't think i
didn't see it
um what else did announce at the 20th oh yeah but after like
oh guess what else was gonna happen what else Coco's gonna
be in that's when they announced Kingdom Hearts 4 uh trailer
I okay I'm gonna give it to you guys straight I love Kingdom
Hearts growing up but I felt like the game peaked in Kingdom
Hearts 1 and 2 and like at this point at Kingdom like I
don't think like I didn't really play Kingdom Hearts 3
because it was such a sludge it was such a sludge like
fucking trying to play that game in 3 I think like 1 and 2
is And honestly, does anyone even remember the plot?
I think everyone stopped remembering the story at 2.
Because I saw a trailer and there were so many people there.
Like, going out, like, everybody's a Keyblade wielder.
Now, it's like, you're a Keyblade wielder.
And you're a Keyblade wielder.
And you're a Keyblade master.
We're all Keyblade masters now.
Oh, Keyblades for everybody.
Like, it's not even special anymore.
It's like, oh yeah, you touch Sora?
You're a Keyblade Master now.
Everybody gets a Keyblade.
Look under your seat, everyone.
Oh my god, what is that?
It's a Keyblade.
Everybody gets, some of you get two.
They trade for practically nothing more.
We're all Sora now.
Oh my god, you like having one?
What about you having two Keyblades?
Whoa!
So I was just like, like, not gonna lie.
I know a lot of people are like super, or are like super
excited about it because they're like, I think at this point
they're just like wondering like, who's, which worlds.
I think the most exciting part about Kingdom Hearts at the
moment is just which Disney World gets to be in uh in
Kingdom Hearts I think that's the build up to it but I mean
it's cool Coco gets to be in Kingdom Hearts now like whoa
who's gonna be in it this time but I can't wait to have uh
area can't wait for Ariel's world to be in Kingdom Hearts
for the day 800th time I but um yeah I think that's just
like I think that's just like what Kingdom Hearts is now so
I'm like I mean it's cool like we get more information about
it but like I said I'm not as hyped about Kingdom Hearts
like everybody else just because I I even I even I played
like I used to I love Kingdom Hearts I got I like I bought
Kingdom Hearts games all the bought the 365 slash five like
i don't know numbers with zion i even bought like i played
that game i played the fucking card game that they ported to
uh consoles i played that but like i think like i don't know
which game i try to play three it was just i try to play
three it was i could not play it i don't know like i stopped
at frozen because it was so i don't know it was just i I try
to play Dream Drop Distance.
I don't know.
Like, it got to the point where I've just lost the plot.
I've actually just lost the plot of all of this.
Like, I didn't even play the prequel with, like, the Roxas
clone and the Blue Kairi.
I don't even remember.
I didn't even, I think I played, like, like.
30 minutes of that one um every i've lost i don't remember
oh be birth by sleep birth by sleep sorry aqua sorry i call
her blue kairi i i call like majority of the girls to me and
for some reason in the game were just different flavors of
kairi uh there's you know there's kairi's nobody which was
yellow kairi and then there's kairi and then there's blue
kairi and then there were two other car and there's black
kairi and then there's one more kairi and i already forgot
all the other kairis i just don't do that yeah yeah blonde
kairi is a blonde kairi there's zion kairi so i just it was
just all kairis to me uh different yeah bacon thank you for
the super chat out in Kingdom Hearts, but let's be honest.
If you can't make fun of it, are you really a fan?
Vega, thank you, Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Simple-minded, thank you, but Super Chat, thank you, thank
you.
If Game of Thrones isn't in Kingdom Hearts, I'm gonna riot,
dokey.
Thank you, but Super Chat, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Lolly, thank you, and Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Can't wait to have the plot held hostage by fucking Winnie
the Pooh via random quest again.
Oh yeah, that's true.
I can't wait to see Winnie again.
Thank you, Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Next, see, thank you, Thank you.
Thank you.
Excuse you.
Aqua was better than Kairi.
Thank you.
Super chat.
That's, that's, Aqua might be like the first Kairi, pre
Kairi.
So like maybe all the Kairis are just Aqua.
So red Aqua, yellow Aqua.
Oh, yeah.
At least Aqua, true.
At least she did stuff.
That's true.
I'll take it.
Yeah.
Fudge.
Thank you for the Super chat.
Thank you.
I hope they have an Avengers endgame moment where Sora has
to fight Thanos or maybe go to Star Wars and slay the
youngest.
I won't be like, I mean, Disney fucking owns everything
right now.
I heard, like, apparently after D23, they added, like,
Universal.
Was it Universal movies into Disney Plus now?
Because they own Universal.
I don't even fucking remember.
I'm losing track of who owns what.
Like, I'm losing track of who owns what now.
Does, does, okay, what, what, what, it's not universal, what
was, I just saw like, okay, Disney Plus added new movies,
what was it, what catalog did they just recently added a
Disney Plus, oh yeah, they added, I heard they added
Jurassic Park and stuff, was it universal, they don't own
universal, what do they own, they own something, but, like,
Jurassic, sick, who owns Jurassic Park?
Own, owner.
Jurassic Park owner.
Not, I'm not talking about John Hammond, I'm talking about
the movie company.
IP owner.
Who owns Jurassic Park?
Oh, is your, I guess they have a deal with universe, oh,
Fox.
I guess they have a deal with, uh, Universal right now to
have some of their stuff on Disney Plus or some shit.
I don't know.
Everybody's in bed with everyone.
I don't know anymore.
Yeah, they probably bought the streaming rights.
They have the money to do that these days.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So, Stoke is interested in starting on time again.
Is it time to rename?
No, it's not, Duck.
That's not an invitation for that.
That's... Duck, it's okay.
It's okay.
No, It's all right, Duck.
I know it's such a hard job.
It's okay.
You should rest, Duck.
You should take a little vacation.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I'm curious what other worlds are going to add in Kingdom
Hearts, though.
Because now that Disney owns Simpsons, you know, anything
can happen.
Banana, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I love that on the mobile game is canon.
Like, they even use real usernames when the Keyblade
Graveyard came to help so That's cool.
I think I'm a super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah, that's the thing.
I remember now That's one of the reasons why like I stopped
carrying is because they got grab plot lines from the
discontinued mobile game To continue the story but the
mobile game only released in Japan or some shit and then had
like a ported They try to Port the movie of the mobile game
of the cutscenes in English, but then it's like who wants to
like It's like, my Disney characters aren't in the fucking
Kingdom Hearts mobile game.
Who the fuck wants to watch these OC's?
Like,
if Goofy and Donald and Mickey are not in these cutscenes,
why the fuck would I want to watch it?
We all, we're practically, okay, these are the people, these
are the characters that everyone only cares about in Kingdom
Hearts.
Roxas and Axel I'm sorry I was not a was it called Roku
what's the Roxas Axel ship name I was not Aku Roku ship
right did not care I I might get cancelled by by by them but
I was not a Aku Roku shipper at all oh yeah the got it
memorized guy um it was All about Roxas, Axel.
And then I get Sora.
I think Roxas was like the number one fan favorite.
And then it was Axel.
And then Axel was not my top five.
I will admit, like, he was not my top five.
But I know it was a lot of people's top fives.
Roxas, Axel, Sora, Riku.
But everybody's top five would be goofy, dog.
Mickey and then Roxas Axel Sora Riku and for me personally
Luxford will be above Sora like we above Axel my top five
goofy Donald Mickey Luxford I'm sorry Luxord Luxord then
Sora the random british guy in organization 13.
that's who's that um the hottest member in organization 13.
that's who like that's my character list like the only
member that i care about like i heard he's and we all saw
him he's gonna be a character in kingdom hearts for i was
like i that's my own okay i will Hearts 4 only because
Luxord is gonna be a character in Kingdom Hearts 4 because I
remember when we saw the trailer I was like oh it's Kingdom
Hearts 4 I was like Luxord like oh my god they brought him
back I think I freaked out over Luxord did anything else in
the fucking game announcement trailer of Kingdom Hearts 4 I
was like freaking out I was like I can't believe he's
actually and he's a gambler did i ship lutezard with anyone
uh i won't talk about it thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you i have to keep reminding myself that kingdom
hearts is also final fantasy crossover i have final fantasy
has soar or mickey mouse in the upcoming expansion i think
it was super chat thank you thank you paturesu thank you a
super chat thank you thank you did you mean zem this which
one uh next scene they give us a super chat thank you thank
you um but released to dokey files yeah i watched the
trailer twice just to see him just to see luke's spirit
again but i think that's the only thing i'm really hyped
about kingdom of hearts for just because the british
gambling man is back He was, I was like, oh my god, I
finally brought him back.
The only character that I cared about in the entire Kingdom
Hearts franchise.
The,
his 10, his 10 fans can finally rejoice that he's back.
And I'm one of them.
I'm one of his 10 fans that just wanted him to come back.
um what else what else but yeah i just i haven't kept track
with king i don't know i don't think anybody knows what's
going on anymore in kingdom hearts like plot wise like
that's why i'm not i haven't really been like very you know
oh kingdom hearts um and and they play sora in tokyo too
they're like tokyo's real guys it i mean we all know it's
real but like tokyo's canon in kingdom Sora is like in Japan
now there's like heartless in Japan um and I was just like
why is he in Tokyo I he's in our world yeah he's like in the
real world now so I was like why why is he there we're get
him back in the get him at least get him I get him somewhere
They made Tokyo real
So it's interesting It's not Tokyo It's Quattratum What's
Quattatum?
Where is that?
I mean, to be fair Modeled after real life Shibuya It's
practically Tokyo I literally googled What is Quattratum?
The first sentence was Modeled after real real life shibuya
so it's sorry sorry quadrat um not tokyo oh oh it's oh oh oh
it got like yokido sorry not tokyo he's in not tokyo
next thing thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
uh calling out your ship was luxured and self-insert it was
not that i had a real ship in there if if you were a luxured
fan you would know what ship it is that's right you're
larping you don't know the real fans will know thank you for
super chat thank you thank you uh spontaneous thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you speaking of mickey which
food is better burger or hot Dog.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're tired of the Mickey burger?
Or Where is that?
What's the correlation?
I like, I personally like hot dogs more than burgers,
though.
Banana.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Only the 10 will know.
Tokyo was already real because the world ends with you
characters appear in the 3DS game.
So it's second Tokyo that isn't the actual Shibuya.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, what was I gonna say?
Uh, what was I gonna say about, uh, what else I was gonna
say about Kingdom Hearts 4?
Uh, but yeah, I didn't, I never really finished Kingdom
Hearts 3.
I think I talked about that a lot of times.
I just, I just didn't, I just found the game.
But when they moved it to Frozen, I thought the game was,
got real, like, it was just, it was just so hard to play.
I was just, I just couldn't keep playing.
I just, I just found it so fucking difficult to play the
game after three.
After the first hour of playing three, um, being stuck in
Frozen World, I just could not keep going.
Uh, Blade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
A Kingdom Hearts fan named Everglow is the one of the few
who made the timeline.
He's a good one keeping the timeline.
Thank you, thank you.
I bet you the director of Kingdom Hearts watches that video,
too.
I mean, he said that he has watched recap videos of the plot
because he has all he has if the director of kingdom hearts
has lost the plot himself like like it's not good quill
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh kingdom
hearts like sour up from smash bros they give me the super
chat thank you thank you um what else oh yeah also they
announced frozen three of course i think what was funny was
3 is that you find out Olaf is straight all along because
they gave him a girlfriend.
And I remember so, I saw a tweet, it was like, and they're
like, what?
He's not gay?
It's not a gay snowman.
And it's like, what?
Yeah, they gave.
He is.
So, so in the announcement for Frozen 3, they were like,
yes, we're going to introduce.
say love interest for Olaf it's a girl snowman it's
literally just like I'm sorry but I thought like okay and
then they're like yeah and he's gonna sing a love song but
he could that's true he might be bi guys he could still be
bisexual and the people were like he's straight the gay
snowman is actually actually straight.
Anyway, there's, um, yes, he can't be happy anymore.
So, anyway, that's, uh, that's Olaf's new girlfriend slash
love interest.
Uh, he's literally a snowman.
Anyway, so that's his, uh, new love interest in frozen and
he's apparently has his name her name Samantha like Duke you
know so much about his new girlfriend because in the
announcement the way they announced it was like here's a
love song he's gonna sing a love song to Samantha the female
snow woman and they were like giving like a preview of the
song um uh so yeah so anyway there's that also a new villain
is going to be announced for frozen 3 what else did they
announce in d23 other than all of that oh yeah new simpson
movie i mean they announced the simpson movie for a while
now but uh they finally showed a trailer of the new
simpson's movie um that i'm fine with it being a sequel
because i think and it's had an animator too.
I was very surprised, like, I was very surprised that they
were actually pan-animating the new Simpsons movie because
they were showing the storyboards and everything, the
keyframes of the Simpsons movie.
So I'm super excited about that.
I've always, I've always loved the original Simpsons movie
and I think the writing was always really, really good.
And so it's going to be pretty exciting.
I think current Simpsons, for those who don't watch Simpsons
anymore, the newest seasons of simpsons are actually pretty
decent like there was a huge slump but i've actually been
watching simpsons because i have disney plus uh for a while
now and i've been enjoying the newer seasons a lot more
there's a there's a there's a point where the newer where
there's a point in the seasons where the newer writers
improved this show a lot more versus like the older writers
in the middle yeah there was a dark ages of simpsons but
right that sort of like a little bit of a revival to like
simpson's writing which i've been watching recently um what
else what else didn't ask we don't care about the marvel
news like i don't think anybody really pays attention to all
the i'm sorry i'm very tired of uh superhero slopp movies
right now like i'm i'm at like a i haven't watched really
marvel movies in a lot i know i play have not, I think like,
I said this before, but I think Marvel movies have like a
rigid, predictable format now.
And it's like, you know, it's like, you got out of a humor.
Yeah, yeah, it has to be funny, but it has to be sad.
It has to be dramatic, but not, but then there's like,
obviously like Disney censorship in there too.
And it's like, it's so predictable now.
Um, And, but I heard the new Spider-Man movie is good.
I heard, like, the Tom Holland Spider-Movie.
Yeah, it's very formulaic, which is why I haven't been
watching.
I don't really watch Marvel films because it's been...
My favorite Marvel films where it have been franchised has
been Guardians of the Galaxy only because I love James Gunn
as a director and I love majority of his works.
We don't talk about the newest one that he did apparently
because I heard that one didn't go so well.
uh i think it's only because he rushed it like but usually
usually they are fire usually they're really really good and
he he was the one that wrote and directed the original
scooby-doo movies too um uh super oh he didn't direct
supergirl okay never mind i thought he i thought he did
supergirl i i assume he did it because supergirl came from
his the james gun cinematic universe so i did okay that
makes more sense superman was fine i i love i not i won't
say i love superman but i enjoyed superman mostly because of
the rage baiting monkeys or chimpanzees that was hilarious i
i love i love the rage bait and chimpanzees i thought that
was a fucking photoshop editor some shit or ai i didn't
realize it came from the actual movie but that that that's
my favorite part the rage baiting monkeys like i am super
mad it's fucking terrible
yeah hashtag super shit yeah so so i love james gunn that's
why i really liked um as director i love like all the stuff
he does like i don't know i just find his directing style
and some something I fuck with um it just like his humor is
just like my humor um that's right capture ain't gonna stop
a chimpanzee like captures are supposed to stop bro like if
but who how would capture stop the chimpanzees though anyway
so um I find Marvel films very formulaic to a point where I
don't really watch Marvel films.
Like I said, the Guardians of the Galaxy is the only really
my favorite franchise and the only one that I actually keep
up to date with.
I know the Spider-Man is really, really good.
I don't know who directs the Spider-Man films, but I've
always heard really good feelings about the Spider-Man
films.
I've only watched the first one from the ones that are from
Tom Holland.
I haven't watched the second or third one, but I know
they're good.
I just, I just not a huge fan of, a huge fan of how
formulaic a lot of them are.
And the fact that you need to keep up to date with a lot of
the other movies, a lot of the other, sorry, Marvel movies
as well to understand the references of what's going on in
other Marvel films.
Like that's just what tires me the most is that you won't
understand some of the storylines some of the references
because they are all connected because it's one giant
cinematic universe.
So that's why I was just like, I like, that's what I have
trouble with the most about Marvel films is just the fact is
like now they have TV shows that also connect with the
movies and like all the TV shows that connect with the
movies and all the side shit that connects with the movies.
and I just I can't be bothered I can't can't be bothered
with that yeah yeah um but yeah anyway so I know a bunch of
Marvel shit got announced but I did not pay attention to to
what other than other than the Doom one because people were
in Mickey Theories being like that's not Robert Downey Jr's
voice that can't be dude but i was like bro robert downy jr
has has pretended to be uh has acted as a black person in a
movie like he has a lot of range like bro that guy was in
tropic thunder guys that man can act i won't i think he just
i'm pretty sure it's just an accent all right
That guy was in Tropic Thunder.
He was playing an Australian man who was playing as a black
person.
He was the greatest African-American actor.
We're not going to go there.
The Ranger Robert Downey Jr. He's not only as Iron Man.
That's right.
That's an actor right there.
He's the dude playing a dude disguised as another dude.
Dudeception.
Oh yeah, and Sherlock Holmes too.
And a British man.
What else?
What else is it announced in D23, guys?
I'm trying to remember right now.
Oh, Bluey.
By the way, there's some Bluey controversy right now.
The Bluey community is not happy right now.
Because...
because um the new bluey movie apparently the trailer reveal
is uh um is that bluey is gonna be in 3d and the bluey
community is not happy right now about that it's it's yeah
yeah there's some there's some discourse right now yeah it's
getting a movie so um so like i said um it's gonna be in 3d
and people are like the the bluey community is not happy
about it not being 2d uh the bluey community has a lot to
say hashtag not my bluey oh yeah zootopia zootopia i think
we all know zootopia 3 is gonna come out you know we're
gonna see uh if the fox and the bunny are finally gonna
start banging okay i read i saw this tweet even i was
thinking about it So you know how like Zootopia was like
everybody is welcome in Zootopia and like the main discourse
for one was like Matt like was just the fact it was like
prey versus predator but then people were like wait a minute
where why is it all just mammals you know And now you're
like, wait a minute, if you think of, and then too, you
found out that they were segregating reptiles.
And too, we're like, oh my God, were the mammals racist?
Like, they're like specious because they're like kicking out
the reptiles.
and yeah like and then they kept stacking on top of each
other and then in three we're gonna find out where the fuck
were the birds because we were like wait a minute where were
the birds so so now we're like all right so now we're gonna
try we're gonna be figuring out in zootopia 3 if the birds
were super racist or also or just didn't like where they
just did not fuck with everybody else or like it was like a
closed gated community or or or they were also kicked out by
the reptiles so we don't know yet we're gonna find out in
three words where the birds lie we're yeah they might
actually be super racist because they're like you guys can't
fly you're not allowed here you're just every movie was just
so another form of discrimination.
Yeah, I would not be surprised if the birds in number three
live in like, I don't know, live in some sky city out there
and they'll be like, don't go down there, those are the
animals that can't fly.
Like, or like be like super elitist, because you're thinking
Zootopia is all about the city where everybody is welcome.
Like, but then why were there no birds?
Like, yeah, I'm like wondering if everybody is welcome, why
are the birds not living in Zootopia?
Like, like, where did they all go?
Oh, yeah, also, also fuck the reptiles.
They also did not fuck with the reptiles, too.
welcome they just didn't want to participate acoustic thank
you super chat thank you thank you zootopia where everyone
is equal but separate thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you um neppers thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you skellies and feathers keep walking this is a furry
neighborhood thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you del thank you for the super chat thank you thank you all
animals are equal but some are more equal than Thank you for
the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So it's gonna be exciting to find out what happens in three.
We're gonna see where the birds lie.
Yeah, oh yeah, and then I guess the fish, I think they're
like in Zootopia Lord, they eat like fishes.
Okay, what do they eat in Zootopia?
I don't think the fishes actually have any rights at all.
Yeah, I remember, because I remember when I was like, I
first saw the movie, I was like, what the fuck do the
predators eat if you can't eat anything else?
So fishes actually have no rights.
They never evolved into like the animals in Zootopia.
So it says, carnivores eat insects and fish.
So and plant protein.
So fish is just, they're just not, I don't know, maybe in 4,
we're going to find out that fishes apparently are fighting
for rights.
too i don't know there we're gonna and i guess in zootopia 4
we're gonna see uh kiagyu thank you super chat thank you
thank you they're gonna keep going till zootopia 10 where
the furries meet the humans thank you thank you thank you
gordon thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
animal farm predicted all of this thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you yeah so so for now we know that
there's not gonna be fishes are not involved in this i mean
dolphins are mammals though i guess you're like thinking
because like um what about like the aquatic mammals in the
ocean because we have these did so show walruses in zootopia
too but and like sea lions and stuff but we never saw like
fish shaped mammals at all so i guess they just to
overcomplicate it i
don't know they might they're just like i don't know what to
do anymore we we we introduce a problem and we're trying to
fix it we have some plows that we gotta address now
so so i guess we'll figure that out in zootopia 5 if we see
any dolphins or walruses and so we saw sea lions and um and
walruses but we You don't know about the, like, sharks are,
and, like, do sharks have rights?
They are fish-shaped, but they are technically a mammal.
Um, wait, are these sharks and mammals?
I know dolphins are mammals, like, sharks, mammals.
Okay, sharks are not mammals.
Okay, that, they're, okay, sharks don't have rights, but
dolphins do.
Dolphins are mammals.
Sharks lay eggs.
Yeah, I forgot.
Sharks do lay eggs.
Because the, uh, because I know, like, some baby sharks will
eat their, their, the other egg.
Um.
Look, I get confused because some shark, like, you know,
some aquatic animals are shaped like fish, but they're not
fish.
So I get confused what is a fish and what isn't a fish.
And I remember sharks do lay eggs.
I've seen a shark egg before, not in person, but in a video.
Much, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll say it.
It's utopia can make more money if it catered to the furries
while also making the new generation of furries, much like
Lion King did.
Instead, they keep shifting, saying, don't worry.
Zootopia 3, it's the build-up, guys.
It's the introduction of the couple, like they first meet
each other in Zootopia 1.
The relationship gets deepened in 2.
And in 3, they're finally going to kiss.
And it's going to be a huge thing, because they're going to
be the first interspecies.
I never thought that would come out of my mouth.
The first interspecies relationship.
And it's going to make headlines, guys.
And in Zootopia 3, it's all about...
how, um, in Zootopia 4, it's gonna be about, like,
interspecies relationships and how it's wrong.
And, like, they're like, that's not natural.
And then they're gonna fight.
It's gonna be, like, um, that Korean, oh, my gosh, one of my
favorite Korean animation.
Um, was it, Dare She Is?
It's gonna be, like, Dare She Is.
Oh, my God, it's gonna be Dare She Is.
It's literally the westernized version of There She Is.
And in Zootopia 4, It's gonna be a whole thing where like
Judy and Nick are gonna fight for the right to be together
Because like we've never seen interspecies relationships In
Zootopia yet And there'll be like the first public famous
interspecies relationship And then they're gonna be fighting
for the right Uh to get be together And that's gonna be
Zootopia 4 And then they'll be like We're like love is love
Love and then and we're gonna see it and then we're gonna
see them fight for what they believe in and then they're
gonna have they're gonna adopt a fox because like i'm gonna
i don't think they're gonna go into the i don't know i think
it's gonna be weird if like because like you know fox rabbit
hybrids i think they're gonna i think they're gonna do a cop
out and they're gonna be like uh they're gonna adopt a bunny
and a fox or some shit instead of like go the route of like
how the fuck are they gonna have kids like
I feel like I feel like it's gonna be weird if I'm trying to
explain how the children's situation is gonna work with the
fox rabbit hybrid so I'm pretty sure they're gonna do the
adoption round yeah time skip they happen to have twins one
a fox and one a rabbit
but it's good that's utopia for I believe in Zootopia 3
they're gonna kiss and then Zootopia 4 we're gonna find out
that there was they are gonna be like the first big
interspecies relationship in Zootopia and then they're gonna
fight for the and it's gonna be there she is it's gonna be
literally it's gonna follow the plot line of there she is
one of my favorite Korean well my favorite web series ever
by the way uh Kyogu they give a super chat thank you thank
you there she is mentioned in 2026 what kind of living in.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Birds aren't allowed in Zootopia because one bird owns a
doja in three kingdoms and things like that.
Thank you.
All right.
Anyway, I think that is a good segue to play the game.
Choice or voicer.
Alright, Toyser Voicer.
What is this game?
So I saw a lot of Twitter clips about Toyser Voicer.
And basically, I think I'll be doing this.
So there's going to be some clips that I have to dub.
And just to see how accurate I dub these clips.
I got to relive the Zootopia game.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Everyone talks about that Zootopia comic.
No one talks about the other comic.
that this artist drew, which I've read.
There's a lot.
There's the Judy Hopps JFK assassination comic, by the way,
that the artist also drew.
No one talks about that one.
That was more extreme than the other ones.
That were more, like, that one was crazy.
By the way, and also no one talks about the fact that post,
post-comic uh judy becomes a lesbian and then marries uh
marries another fox woman and then she's a prostitute she
was a prostitute right like i'm not a larper like some of
you guys about that com you only saw one of the comic i saw
more of it so yeah so anyway after that comic uh she runs
for president or mayor or some shit and then uh and then she
dates a she dates a female fox that she met from counseling
and and then apparently she was an ex-prostitute and then
there was one i don't know it was an april fools comic that
the artist made where uh she parodied the jfk And then the
next panel would be like JK was just ketchup
Bro what the fuck Bryce, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you weird flex, but all right, Doki What I was
curious.
I wanted to know what goes on in that artist's head You know
cuz it was clearly not the only comic she drew like I Tiago,
thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Patrick, Esther, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, yeah, it was strawberry jam.
Oh, sorry.
There's a guy.
Maybe I'm the larpers.
Sorry, I didn't remember what fucking flavor of red it was.
Patrick, Esther, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Because you're like, you want to know, you want to know,
like, what goes in this artist's head.
Like, okay, they drew that comic.
What else have they done?
Of course, I read all the other comics that she did, because
I got curious.
I don't know if she's still drawing.
It's on Demon Art, by the way.
I don't know if she's kept going.
I just know that the last one I read was the assassination
one.
Old man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Are we doing custom clip dubs?
I heard about that.
The Asian one?
Yeah, I saw that, too, on Twitter.
make sure apparently some of the custom clips are like
pretty sketchy so i have to like go through it and make sure
there's nothing bad there so um so i'll look into that too
we'll have to hear dokey dub the family guy think of a super
chat thank you thank you we're gonna be hard stuck bronzing
yapping leaderboards dragons i think i think i'm climbing
the rankings of the yapping
your E-Logos.
Ivan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The yapping part is where you want to raise it.
The lay part is where you want to lower it.
So I'm at the moment, I'm min-maxing right now.
Unintentionally, I just wanted to talk about D23.
I'm very passionate about Disney stuff.
We want, I'm already, I'm already rink, I want to rink two.
I'm, rink two.
I'm min-maxing, lowering the lateness and maxing the
yappness.
Alright, anyway.
Anyway, choicester voicester.
Dev actually, like, replied to my tweet, too, like, the
waiting room tweet, being, like, well, apparently one of his
friends is a dragoon, as well, and was, like, telling him,
like, oh, Jokey's going to play it.
So, yeah.
I'm pretty excited.
Check the game out.
um um i like i said it's just dubbing some clips that are
shown to us and i'm gonna i just think about it should i
mute my like i'm gonna mute myself on stream while i'm
dubbing it and then like so then you guys can like be
surprised when you hear the full thing or do you want me to
dub it live with you guys like what do you guys want you
want to be surprised at the dub at the want to dub it live
I just mute myself on stream mute okay so you want to be
surprised it's gonna be so by the way I am not a voice actor
guys whichever is funny well obviously the first one is
funnier
well we'll try muting we'll do we'll start with muting And
then live we'll do live dubbing later.
How about that?
We'll do 50 50.
We'll do mute first and just to be just to keep you on your
toes just to see what what it's gonna be like But anyway,
I'm really bad at voice acting by the way.
I'm really bad at it because like I just know how to do two
voices So it's gonna be interesting how this is gonna go
like Not a very good.
I'm not very good at creating voices.
I can just do my voice It's just gonna be Pete.
It's gonna be Peter, but somehow she Somehow he sounds like
Doki Bird.
Peanut.
All right, here we go.
I downloaded the game.
Let me see.
All right, standard.
How do I download the clips for this game anyway?
We'll find out live.
We'll find out everything live.
All right.
Yeah, I'm basically the Chris Pratt of Voice.
acting of v-tubing but like not the not all the bad stuff
though all right let's see choicer voicer um i assume i can
i'm gonna make it this i assume i can do full screen later
my name is shan i'm the show's default apparently this game
was made for vinnie or something it was like a game designed
for vinnie and then it got really popular so now it's for
everybody It's a slime girl.
I assume she's a slime girl.
She looks like one.
Alright, it looks like this might be your first time.
Feel free to ask me any questions.
Yeah, from Vine Sauce.
Alright.
How to customize.
One of our prime goes, making it easier to customize your
experience.
Each feature has its own pack folder in your game directory.
And you, like, click this button to open... Alright, let
me...
Haunt this.
And take a look.
Oh!
I see.
Okay.
oh i opened it again now i have two folders current features
are chatter host judge menu play studio and voice or content
by belongs on one of these pack folders you might say
tutorial pack in pack voice we need a new content pack make
sure to drop and merge it with the correct pack folder else
it won't work also create a new pack template from the
customization additionally the mod pack guide page lists
every file available to you all right um how to play you
play a session I want to do the one with the clips.
Alright, I want to say I'm going to finish with.
Okay, we're not doing that one.
Alright, let me see if there's a way to full screen this.
Extra settings.
Ah, there we go.
There we go.
I knew there was one.
Gameplay option.
There's too many things to look at.
Alright, sound guy.
Let me know if the volume's okay.
mic test and press oh that is that's the last and it's fine
i'm not gonna look into this i all right let's see save and
return i'm gonna customize see
uh let's see mod pack guys guys which one is the guys uh
guys all right we don't have to customizing thing.
Alright, so which one is the one that everybody's playing on
right now?
Which one is it?
Is it studio?
Is it?
Which one?
There's so many packs, guys.
I don't know what this is.
I'm too scared.
Is it dub mode?
Which one is it is it this dub mode okay dub mode everyone's
doing dub mode okay open folder all right now where do i get
where do i get it all right what's this dub cinema is that
it no that's not it oh that's where you watch it all right
so Dub mode.
How do I get mod packs, guys?
How do I... Where do I... How do I get mod packs?
Because I thought that they would show me where, but
apparently they don't.
Do I... Okay, let me look it up.
Let me Google.
Choicer, Voicer, mod packs.
I'll just Google it.
Oh, it's on Game Banana.
Oh, Choicer, Voicer, website?
Choicer, website all right welcome to choice your voice here
I hope this is the right one custom content dub packs all
right creating a dub pack okay stored page right fuck are
the where are the packs for this we're doing guys it's
because I'm worry about getting the wrong clips So we're
doing it live with you guys.
Okay choice your voice your dub pack All right dub pack
cereal.
I found it All right Do it live like current content hot
burger king foot lettuce weird fucking cat all right These
are safe Question mark
They seem pretty safe.
There's so many.
I'm just...
Alright, I'm going to try and get ones where I don't...
Where it seems like I won't get hit by anything.
All right, what are the most downloaded ones?
I know there was like Twitch clips, too.
Peter bought a tank.
There's so many.
Oh, my God.
Wait, there's so many choices.
I don't know now.
Wait a minute.
Oh, my.
Wait, this is hard.
There's so many choices.
Oh, I'm really bad at picking up.
picking guys do you know Mario guys I will not be sounding
like Mario so many choicers choices is my choicer voicer
deaf note the world hey let's do a deaf note clip which one
is this though shit we're ever is our stream gonna be
demonetized oh obviously is our stream gonna be watchable
all right wait is this deaf oh it's the world it's the song
i thought i was gonna dub over uh deaf note i didn't say i
don't think there's a i don't think there's a dokey clip
there's like so many of these clips are in other languages
so i'm like i don't know which one oh there's too many
choices guys i'm so bad at picking
God you ever get like you ever get like stun lock because
there's so many things to pick that's me right now I'm like
stun locked at the moment with too many choices and my
choice is voicing I'm like oh what do I pick oh oh I got one
wait I got one wait wait let's see okay so Solo?
Boy, I got one.
I got a good one.
Oh, bring the music slider down.
Okay, wait.
Wait, give me a sec.
We have exit.
I don't, I want to surprise you guys.
When you see the clip, I want to surprise you guys.
All right.
All right, let me know if it's...
This is why I do it live.
It's funnier too.
When I find the one I want.
Stand ready for my arrival, worm.
Okay.
Okay, wait.
Stand ready for my arrival, worm.
Okay, all right.
All right, here we go.
Oh, oh, this is gonna be hard, doesn't it?
Simple.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
some money now pick a family after this we'll do a family
guy clip all right okay okay okay i'm gonna mute myself
while we this is gonna be i'm gonna mute myself for this one
okay stand ready for my arrival worm
stand ready for my arrival worm okay okay i don't even know
if that's gonna be you were given orders you were given time
all right you were given orders you were given time all
right here we go you were given orders you were given time
okay oh okay here we go oh it's 11.
given more leeway than most and yet i find this planet holy
that is so long oh my this is definitely a monologue you
were given more leeway than most and yet i find this planet
unprepared for the arrival of our built from empire and you
listen again you were given more leeway than most and yet i
find this planet unprepared for the arrival of our built
from empire okay okay okay
You were given more leeway than most, and yet I find this
planet unprepared for the arrival of our Viltrum Empire.
You were given...
You were given more leeway than most, and yet I find this
planet unprepared for the arrival of our Viltrum Empire.
I don't... I hope it sounds good.
Like, I don't know.
I don't know if it's gonna sound good, guys.
I hope it sounds good.
Because I don't get to hear it back at all until the end.
I can only hear it back until the end.
The Empire anticipated your resistance, which is why they
sent me.
Okay.
The Empire anticipated your resistance, which is why they
sent me.
anticipated your resistance, which is why they sent me.
The empire anticipated your resistance, which is why they
sent me.
Okay, okay, okay, next one.
Oh, I'm only halfway there.
And I am your last chance to fulfill your duty.
Oh, I thought this was the one where he's like, I'm so
lonely.
We'll do that one later.
This is just like, like the foreshadowing.
I thought this was a clip where he's like, I'm so lonely,
but it's not.
It's the introduction.
So we're just introducing.
It's foreshadowing.
I wanted to do that one.
I thought that one was funny.
I am conquest.
And I am your last chance to fulfill your duty.
Okay.
Seeing their mouth moving silently while conquest speaks.
So it looks like it's coming from her is perfect.
Lolly, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I am conquest and I am your last chance to fulfill your
duty.
All right, next one.
Good.
Growl!
Good Good
Good Good Good
Good Good Good Good Good This isn't a good time Shit, I'm
Mark now wait i was expecting to be mark i thought she was
gonna be conquest the entire time fuck i gotta be a pussy
now okay
this isn't a good time this isn't a good time this isn't a
good time this isn't a good time this isn't a good time you
don't understand you don't understand you don't understand
all this I'm speedrunning Mark by the way he's not important
speedrunning him I don't care about what he has to say it's
all about conquest I don't care about what he has to say
guys all this this is my fault all this this is my fault so
the only thing i want to do why is it so much mark i don't
care the only thing i want to do right now so the only thing
i want to do right now so the only thing i want to do right
now so the only thing i want to do right now so the only
thing i want to do right now is hit something as hard as i
can oh my gosh okay is hit last one as hard as i can is hit
something as hard guys i forgot his name his actor's name um
he's so good at voice acting though like i know he can only
do he can also only do one voice just like me but he's so
good at his one voice you know he's hit something as hard as
i can he just can it's just no not alex it's no it's steve
un yeah it's steve un alex does his alex lee does his uh
video game voiceover uh but steven un um voice acts uh for
mark and like he's so good at voice acting and also as an
one voice which is his own voice it's just his own voice but
he's so good at it like you feel so much emotion from it too
is hit something as hard as i can is hit something as hard
as i can is hit something as hard as i can is hit something
as hard as i can is hit something as hard as i can All
right.
You'll get there.
To be fair, I wasn't trying to sound like them.
I will say I wasn't trying to sound like them.
I was trying to...
Like I said, I can't fucking sound like anyone.
I just sound like me.
Okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yo, Doki.
Don't know if you heard of...
Localist, blind box model, but the new wave of the
Transformers light has your boy Brainstorm of his briefcase
too.
Oh my god, there's back.
Oh my god, Brainstorm got some love.
All right, thank you for this to reach out.
Thank you.
All right, I'm tempted to just hear it myself.
Oh, do I hear it?
Okay, I don't know if it's gonna be good.
All right, all right, let's see the final product.
Stand ready for my rival dragon.
What?
You were given orders, you were given time.
You were given more leeway than most and yet I find this
planet unprepared for the arrival of our dragon empire.
This isn't a good time.
The empire anticipated your resistance which is why they
sent me.
I am conquest and I am your last chance to fulfill.
Your duty.
They don't understand.
All this?
This is my fault.
It's just Doki.
The only thing I want to do right now is hit something as
hard as I can.
It's just Doki.
I told you a cat voice actor.
I just sound like me.
It's just all toky.
What do you mean you're a good voice actor?
Push.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's all toky always has been.
Alright, let's...
We'll be watching again for it to be louder.
That's my voice actor.
Bring the clip playback to 70.
Okay.
Alright, let's leave it.
Is it better?
Stand ready for my rival dragon.
Oh, the voice lighter.
You were given orders, you were given time.
You were given more leeway than most, and yet I find this
planet unprepared for the arrival of our dragon empire.
This isn't a good time.
The empire anticipated your resistance, which is why they
sent me.
It sounded like Vegeta, the Canadian version.
You don't understand.
All this?
This is my fault.
So the only thing I want to do right now.
Gakarat.
I can't believe they are here to push God's quest.
First of all, hi, I'm Vegeta.
Thank you to Patrick Warburton of YouTubers for voice
acting.
This is actually so fun, and they were so good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm glad someone thinks I'm doing a great job.
The game does it.
I had 38%.
The game was like, I had a 38, brother.
Yeah, I don't know why, but Conquest Sir, it sounds like one
of the twins in the Rugrats.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is everything else.
Sound guy.
Let me know what I should reset.
You'll get there someday.
You could do, I'll play it one more time.
We're doing auto-balancing right now.
You're right, as long as my target audience loves it, that's
good enough for me.
Bro, good.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, do we do the clip back a little bit more, too?
I'll put a hundred.
Maybe it'll go up more.
Let's try maxing clip playback.
All right.
Let's go.
Round three.
Stand ready for my rival, Dragoon.
You were given orders.
You were given time.
You were given more leeway than most.
And yet, I find this planet unprepared for the rival of our
Dragoon Empire.
I think my...
I, like, got the lip flaps really good.
The lip flaps?
I am conquest.
So good.
It very synced up.
to fulfill your duty you don't understand all this this is
my fault so the only thing i want to do right now is hit
something as hard as i can
all right all right round four round four because we're just
we're gonna keep watching this until we get it right all
right master to a hundred uh clip play back to 40
okay i'll put 50.
and then forces back down to 50 i'll put 60.
i'm rounding it up all right all right let's try again let's
try we're just trying there are more sliders yeah but These
are- these are for microphone.
None of these matter.
It's all about this.
These don't matter.
This is just me fucking around with microphone.
Did I hear round four?
Round- we're just making sure we gotta get the clip playback
good, guys.
Stand ready for my rival dragon.
the obs too
you were given orders you were given time you were given
more leeway than most and yet I find this planet unprepared
for the arrival of our dragon Empire this isn't a good time
the Empire anticipated your resistance which is why they
sent me I am conquest and I am your last chance to fulfill
your duty you don't understand all this this is my fault so
the only thing i want to do right now is hit something as
hard as i can oh my god
yeah i've voice acted that too that scream i did that too
sliders don't mean anything they're not gonna lie sliders
don't really aren't really as accurate all right let me good
all right let's save i'll save the dub i'll save it so we
can re-watch it again if you close your eyes it actually
sounds really good you definitely voice back personally i
love to do a voice pack of your reading scripts Cyber, thank
you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, apparently it's not, I don't know why the slider's not
working.
Alright, what's ExpandView?
Oh, oh my god, wait, we could have watched it in HD.
Okay, what's cinema?
Oh, is it cinema?
Oh my god, I could watch, I could watch it in cinema.
Oh my god, it's like watching a movie An HD You were given
order It's like watching a movie Yeah, no, we're not gonna
watch it again We watched it a lot We already watched it a
lot
Okay Alright, let me find another one clips you can dub
Lolly thank you with a super chat thank you thank you the
cinema oh I got a good one wait I got another good one all
right a little more and then that brings sound effects all
right I'll bring a little bit up more but give me a second
let me I got good one I got a really good one I'm gonna
surprise you guys every time oh and not this folded we're my
voice back folder there it is I got another good one that
showed up Darius thank you super chat that you think is the
opening cinematic for a soul river to elaborate out voice
king if you do Raziel Darius thank you with super chat they
could think I have no idea I'm just I'm just looking through
the website and there's a lot of really good ones already oh
my god there's another invincible one yes more invincible
all right all right you guys ready oh yeah let me turn down
sound and sound effects this part works really well yeah up
a little bit more all right guys ready
Shit is 17.
All right, do you want to do live dubbing or do you want
muted dubbing guys?
What do you think you'll in?
This is the first time I've seen the entire scene like
instead of like the high ground All right, do you guys want
One mute or muted dub or you like it muted?
Yeah
But it was far.
I'll do muted.
You turned her against me.
Okay.
I will say they're all just gonna sound like me.
I'm not doing a voice whatsoever.
You will not take her from me.
Don't lecture me, Obi-Wan.
I see through the lies of the Jedi Okay, okay Guys, I will
have you say I've never seen the full scene before I've only
seen the part Where oh, where he's like I have the high
ground now And then he's just And then Anakin's just
screaming That's the only point of reference I have this is
the first time I've seen the entire scene And it's through
this game So I was like There's a lot of dialogue for this I
did not know that.
I only saw the memes.
All right.
Okay, here we go.
Let me see.
Don't lecture me, Obi-Wan.
I see through the lies of the Jedi.
Yeah.
Don't lecture me, Obi-Wan.
I see through the lies.
Oh, the mic input multiplier.
Which one?
This?
How much do you want to increase?
How much you want?
They want me to increase.
They want me to increase the multiplier so it can be louder
for us.
We'll let the sound guide aside.
There's one.
Let's try three.
All right, let's see.
Don't lecture me, Obi-Wan.
I see through the lies of the Jedi.
don't lecture me obi-wan i see through the lies of the jedi
i do not fear the dark side as you do okay all right the
dark side as you do i do not fear the dark side as you do i
do not fear the dark side as you do i do not fear the dark
side as you do
I have brought peace, freedom, justice.
Give me the part where you burn your legs.
And he goes, I have the high ground.
That's all I want to say.
I just want to say that.
I have the high ground now.
I just want that.
I have brought peace.
That's a different scene.
This isn't even a scene I want.
All right.
Everybody, this is foreshadowing.
This is foreshadowing.
This isn't even the scene I wanted.
It's not even this scene.
I just saw them in the cave.
I just saw them in the volcano.
And I was like, oh my god.
I just saw it.
I thought it was that scene.
Because I saw them in the volcano.
This is to bring the context.
Fine.
Yeah.
This is the context, by the way.
I told you guys I was the Larpid.
know about this movie is the part where uh the little like
is the part where like his legs start burning off and he's
like i have the high ground that's all i know i have brought
peace freedom justice i have brought peace freedom justice i
have brought peace freedom justice i have brought peace
freedom justice
to my new empire jesus christ god you're so email and
security 17 scenes okay and security to my new empire and
security to my new empire and security to my new empire
don't make me kill you oh yeah that's what i like to see
yeah don't make me kill you
you don't make me kill you don't make me kill you if you're
not with me then you're my enemy if you're not with me we're
halfway there guys we're halfway there if you're not with me
then you're my enemy if you're not with me then you're my
enemy you will try you will try you will try all right i
will say this actor's not that great i'm sorry he's so flat
like his his his intonation is so like he's one to murder
this man and it's like it's so flat yourself you have done
that yourself we take it back
you are right i just i just feel like i feel like it's a
he's a little like all right he's he's giving it all he's
got It's pretty bad directing.
Yeah, maybe the direct...
It was poorly directed.
Yeah, it's very monotone for, like, what he wants to do.
You have done that yourself.
I feel more feeling from him here.
There's not going to be any accent here.
There's not...
There's not- I- I know we all want me to have accent here,
but I don't know if I can pull it off.
You have done that yourself.
All right, thank you for the raid, guys.
We're- we're- we're starting- I'm starting my professional
voice acting career right now.
We had a good stream this month.
and your lust for power have already done that your anger
and your lust for power have already done that you have
allowed this dark lord to twist your mind until now until
now what you have allowed this dark lord to twist your mind
until now okay i remember the fights being hardcore like i
remember that you have allowed this dark lord to twist your
mind until now right thank you for the five give the ships
thank you thank you those are we're new here we're wondering
what the is going on i'm doing a muted dub i'm muting myself
on stream so you guys can hear it like fully live when it's
all done so we can all be surprised you have allowed this
dark lord to twist your mind until now you have allowed this
dark lord to twist your mind until now until now you have
become the very thing you swore to destroy all right oh
you're about to get on you're about to get on with it.
Clip 13.
There's so many clips.
Until now, you have become the very thing you swore to
destroy.
Your new empire.
Oh, my gosh.
Alright.
Here you go.
Oh, oh, he's all that You hear that motion in there?
Your new empire.
Anakin, my allegiance is to the Republic.
To democracy.
Oh, yeah.
Speak your truth, Obi-Wan.
To democracy.
Speak your truth.
There's no accent, by the way.
I cannot do an accent.
We're not putting any accent in here.
There's only one voice.
voice that i can do and it's jokie bird Anakin my allegiance
is to the republic to democracy Anakin my allegiance is to
the republic to democracy Anakin my allegiance is to the
republic to democracy only a sith deals in absolutes all
right we're speeding through this i'm almost done i'm gonna
speedrun the next two no more commentary for now until this
we got two left only a sith deals in absolutes only a sith
deals in absolutes only a sith deals in absolutes i will do
what i must i will do what i must i will do what i must i
will do what i must all right fall improving i'm getting
better it's it's an upgrade it's a sorcerer thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you you don't understand
turkey the cheese is part of this the chat guys all right
are you guys ready all right let's do expand oh wait should
we do excel let's do expand view
better are you guys ready oh wait never mind not expand oh
wait maybe you turn her against me you have done that
yourself you will not take her from me your anger and your
lust for power have already done that
You have allowed this Dark Lord to twist your mind Until now
Until now you have become the very thing You swore to
destroy Don't lecture me, Obi-Wan I see through the lies of
the Jedi I do not fear the dark side as you do I have
brought peace Freedom Justice And security to my new empire
Your new empire don't make me kill you anakin my allegiance
is to the republic to democracy if you're not with me then
you're my enemy I'm just talking to myself deals in
absolutes I will do what I must you will try
I'm just talking to myself.
I'm having an argument with myself right now.
It's a democracy.
My internal monologue.
I told you I don't know how to do voice-to-voice.
I'm just like, I'm just talking.
You versus the voice, you versus the voices in your head.
Don't keep trying to fight or fool you aside.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Oh, all right.
Henry, thank you for the super chat.
This, this, you're definitely getting demonetized.
by the way.
I will not be surprised if this stream has is blocked in
some countries.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Alright.
Next.
Next clip.
This is my petition for the Doki Dopp of the Revenge of the
SIP.
Cindy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do we...
I got a good thing.
Okay, I'm not gonna do this this one next.
I'm gonna All right, let's I'm still looking through I'm
looking through to see what else to do Oh my god, this is
fun.
This is pretty fun
Yeah, I'm trying oh wait, I got I got one guys.
It's like me playing with my Barbie You guys, like, yeah, I
got a good one.
Alright.
Sorry, sorry.
There's so many good ones.
I'm trying to...
Alright, I'm a surgeon, doctor.
Patrick has to thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Gio.
Thank you, with the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Shit, okay.
Alright, wait, wait.
Alright.
Okay, all right, I'm sorry.
There's so many good ones.
So I'm trying to...
I'm trying to...
Try to pick the best one for us right now.
There's too many good ones, guys.
It's very hard to pick.
All right, all right.
Okay.
Let's see.
We'll do this one first.
Um...
I'm having too much fun right now.
all right all right all right next one all right so sound
guys a better has it been better sound guys is it better now
all right bring the bring the clip playback up all right
it's up it's up
It's up.
All right.
That one, right?
Do you want me to bring voices up too?
Do you want me to bring voices up?
All right.
I'll bring you up a little bit.
All right, you guys ready for the clip?
I downloaded a couple of ones, but we're going to do this
one first.
but we're not doing that that I don't think I can do that 22
I'm sorry we're not I can't do 22 okay I can't do 22 guys
that's a bit too many voice acting sorry I have to cut 22
don't worry I got good one I have a I downloaded another one
though do not worry do not worry if it was a 22 I would be
fine.
I forgot how long that scene is.
Might as well dump the entire episode.
Alright, here we go.
Don't worry, I got a good one.
I got a good one.
This is a good one.
This one, I'll do what chapter length it is.
This is the closest thing I get.
Okay.
get all right this is the closest thing i get
this is the closest thing i get this is the closest thing i
get this is the closest thing i get
fun stop thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you
please we need smiley friends to get Oh, dude, there's
another smiley friends.
We'll do the other one.
I think that one's shorter.
That one might be shorter.
I think, I don't know.
The clip for the recording for this is a little ass.
Not gonna lie.
What is, what's going on?
what what is this what is this clip slightly evil laughter
what is going on
i've set things up so the criminals will continue to die
over the next three weeks okay okay now now we're getting to
the good part now now we're it's the lead up it's lead up
guys i've set things up so the criminals will continue to do
you want me no commentary we're gonna fast track this okay
i've set things up so the criminals will continue to die
over the next three weeks i've set things up so the
criminals will continue to die over the next three weeks
i've set things up so the criminals will continue to die
over the next three three weeks.
But El is aware by now that Kida can control the times of
death of his victims.
Therefore, to avoid suspicion.
Therefore, to avoid suspicion, L needs to see that criminals
whose names are being broadcast continue to die while I have
no access to that information.
L needs to see that criminals whose names are being
broadcast continue to die while I have no access to that
information.
L needs to see that criminals whose names are being
broadcast continue to die while I have no access to that
information.
L needs to see that criminals whose names are being
broadcast continue to die while I have no access to that
information.
L needs to see that criminals whose names are being
broadcast continue to die while I have no access to that
information.
I'm gonna show you L.
With Ryuk's information and my preparations, with Ryuk's
information and my preparations, With Ryuk's information and
my preparations, I can continue to kill criminals whose
names are broadcast on the news.
I can continue to kill criminals whose names are broadcast
on the news.
While masquerading as a typical high school student studying
for his entrance exams.
Oh god, that's so...
I forgot how fucking itch lowered his dialogue.
guys that's it he's so edged lord oh my god what a fucking
edgy boy while masquerading as a typical high school student
studying for his entrance exams while masquerading as a
typical high school student studying for his entrance exams
while masquerading as a typical high school student studying
for his entrance exams
as a typical high school student studying for his entrance
exams.
Just watch me, Elle.
I'll solve equations with my right hand and write names with
my left.
Oh my god.
So fucking it.
What's that word called?
Tuny to so tuny.
Just watch me, Elle.
I'll solve equations with my right hand and write names with
my left.
Just watch me, Elle.
I'll solve equations with my right hand and write names with
my left.
Just watch me, Al.
I'll solve equations with my right hand and write names with
my left.
I'll take a potato chip and eat it.
eat it i'll take a potato chip and eat it i'll take a potato
chip i'll take a potato chip and eat it i'll take a potato
chip and eat it
What the fuck am I going to do this?
That's going to be, yeah, I'm going to do that laugh.
How the fuck am I going to do Ryu Kus?
Oh, the symptoms are starting.
Oh, improvement.
It's getting better.
It's getting better, guys.
I'm getting better at it.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
This is the closest he can get.
I've set things up so that criminals will continue to die
over the next three weeks Elle is aware by now that Kira can
control the times of death of his victims therefore to avoid
suspicion Elle needs to see that criminals whose names are
being broadcast continue to die while have no access to that
information The symptoms are starting!
I'm gonna show you, L.
With Ryuk's information and my preparations, I can continue
to kill criminals whose names are broadcast on the news,
while masquerading as a typical high school student studying
for his entrance exams.
Just watch me, L.
I'll solve equations with my right hand and write names with
my left.
I'll take a potato chip and eat it.
But, um...
Oh,
you're kidding.
I had said...
She said the thing!
She said it!
She said the thing, guys!
It's a bit too sensual.
She said it.
I ate the chip.
I'll save it.
Wow, this is better than...
You can't say that.
I just...
It was just...
I'm just talking to myself.
I think my favorite part is just my lap with Ryu.
He's like...
I'm just like, what do I do?
I don't know.
I do Ryu.
Stop.
Thank you for the five.
Give the chips.
Thank you.
Cyber, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, cinema.
But we're thinking of the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Natural born Junie.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hearing the English dub, I see how Netflix death note has
happened.
Oh, my God.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
There's this amazing death note troll fake.
you're dark you got me you'd be great for voicing a dramatic
greeting i'll think about that i know a lot about that one
thank you the akasupa thank you thank you rice thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you bonus content for the
stream is here in the original lines coming from toky's lips
laps you guys want to watch that again yeah i saw somebody
like please let's i want to see it again do you guys
actually want to see that again
One more time.
I think my favorite part is just, like, watching it all live
together.
This is the closest he can get.
I've set things up so that criminals will continue to die
over the next three weeks.
that Kira can control the times of death of his victims.
Therefore, to avoid suspicion, L needs to see that criminals
whose names are being broadcast continue to die while I have
no access to that information.
Oh, the symptoms are starting!
I'm going to show you, L.
Pump, pump, pump.
No, no, no, no, no, pump, pump, pump.
With Ryuk's information and my preparations, I can continue
to kill criminals whose names are broadcast on the news.
masquerading as a typical high school student studying for
his entrance exams.
Just watch me yell.
I'll solve equations with my right hand and write names with
my left.
I'll take a potato chip and eat it.
I'm done!
Bump, bump, bump.
There it is.
I ate the potato chip, guys.
Alright, oh, I got a good one.
I gotta, don't worry.
I downloaded a lot of good ones.
Alright, this one.
This one is good.
This one.
This is a good one.
I quote this quite often to you guys, too.
It's even better.
Bravo!
It's even better a second time!
Sound guy, how has it been so far?
Are you guys ready for this one?
It's classic.
The reoclimate is what Doki says to yourself when the blood
moon rises.
Birkin bond, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
try this.
41!
Alright, we're speedrunning.
Guys, we have to speedrun this.
Okay, no commentary.
There's 41 I have to do.
Seymour, the house is on fire!
I don't know how to do an old person's voice.
I...
Oh!
Seymour, the house is on fire!
Seymour, the house is
Oh, Superintendent John Welcome.
I hope you're prepared for an unforgettable luncheon.
Ah, Superintendent Chalmers, welcome.
Oh you gods, my roast is ruined!
But what if I were to purchase fast food and disguise it as
my own cooking?
What if I were to purchase fast food and disguise it as my
own cooking?
But what if I were to purchase fast food and disguise it as
my own cooking?
Ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho,
ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho,
ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho ho, ho ho ho
ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho, ho ho ho ho ho
ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho,
ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho ho!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, delightfully devilish, Seymour.
Superintendent, I was just, uh, stretching my calves on the
windowsill.
Isometric exercise.
Care to join me?
Superintendent, I was just, uh, stretching my calves on the
windowsill.
Isometric exercise.
Care to join me?
Superintendent, I was just, uh, stretching my calves on the
windowsill.
exercise care to join me oh this is hard this is so hard
guys this is so hard he talks so fast I did not realize that
superintendent I was just uh stretching my calves on the
windowsill isometric exercise care to join me uh oh that
isn't smoke it's steam steam from the steamed clams we're
having Mmm, steamed clams.
I'm 9 out of 40.
I forgot how long the scene is.
It'll be all worth it.
Oh, that isn't smoke.
It's steam.
Steamed from the steamed clams we're having.
Mmm, steamed clams.
Uh, oh, that isn't smoke.
It's steam.
Steamed from the steamed clams we're having.
Mmm.
steamed clams oh that is in smoke it's steam steamed from
the steamed clams we're having mmm steamed clams oh
superintendent I hope you're ready for mouth-watering
hamburgers superintendent I hope you're ready for
mouth-watering Superintendant, I hope you're ready for
mouth-watering hamburgers.
No, no, I said steamed hams.
That's what I call hamburgers.
Yes, it's a regional dialect.
Uh, upstate New York?
Oh, not in Utica, no, it's an Albany expression.
Not in Utica.
No, it's an Albany expression.
Oh, no.
Patented Skinner Burgers.
Old family recipe.
Oh, no.
Patented Skinner Burgers.
Old family recipe.
Oh, no.
Patented Skinner Burgers.
Old family recipe.
Yes.
You know the...
One thing I should...
Excuse me for one second.
You know the...
One thing I should...
Excuse me for one second.
You know the...
One thing I should...
Excuse me for one second.
You know the...
You know, the...
One thing I...
Excuse me for one second.
Oh, well, that was wonderful.
Good time was had by all.
I'm pooped.
Oh, well, that was wonderful.
Good time was had by all.
I'm pooped.
Oh, well, that was wonderful.
Good time was had by all.
I'm pooped.
Oh, well, that was wonderful.
Good time was had by all.
I'm pooped.
Sorora Borealis.
Yes.
No.
No, mother, it's just the Northern Lights.
Well, Seymour, I made it, despite your directions.
Ah.
Seymour!
Why is there smoke coming out of your oven, Seymour?
I thought we were having steamed clams.
You call hamburger steamed hams.
Uh-huh.
What region?
Really?
Well, I'm from Utica, and I've never heard anyone use the
phrase steamed hams.
Really?
Well, I'm from Utica, and I've never heard anyone use the
phrase steamed hams.
Really?
Well, I'm from Utica, and I've never heard anyone use the
phrase steamed hams.
and I've never heard anyone use the phrase steamed hams.
I see.
You know, these hamburgers are quite similar to the ones
they have at Krusty Burger.
Four steamed hams.
steamed ham's for steamed hams yes and you call them steamed
hams despite the fact they are obviously grilled yes and you
call them steamed hams despite the fact they are obviously
grilled yes and you call them steamed hams despite the fact
they are obviously grilled yes and you call them steamed
hams despite the fact they are obviously grilled of course
of course of course yes i should be good lord what is
happening in there yes i should be good lord what is
happening in there uh aurora borealis at this time of year
at this time of day and this part of the country localized
entirely within your kitchen.
Aurora Borealis, at this time of year, at this time of day
in this part of the country, localized entirely within your
kitchen.
Aurora Borealis, at this time of year, at this time of day
in this part of the country, localized entirely within your
kitchen.
Aurora Borealis, at this time of year, in this part of the
country localized entirely within your kitchen.
Mash it.
Well, Seymour, you are an odd fellow, but I must say, you
steam a good ham.
I just keep getting better.
A jokie bird stream at this time of the year, at this time
of the day, in this part of the country, localized entirely
within YouTube.
Thank you for the super chat, Acer.
Thank you.
Oh, I just keep improving.
What can I say?
I just keep getting better.
I can only go up guys I think it's gonna be really scuffed
there's gonna be a lot of cut dialogue because I have no
there was like barely any room to make this like there was
like not a lot of like space I'll just say for this it's
gonna be very scuffed so we'll see how this goes
well Seymour I made it despite your directions ah
superintendent Chalmers welcome I hope you're prepared for
an unforgettable luncheon.
Meh.
Oh, you guys!
My roast is ruined!
But what if I were to the precious fast food and skies as my
own cooking?
Oh, delightfully devilish, Seymour.
Uh...
There, Mr. Explanation.
Bama, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da, da,
da, Slave exaggeration There'll be trouble in town tonight
Seymour!
Superintendent, I was just Just stretching my calves on the
windowsill Isometric exercise, Gary to join me Why is there
smoke coming out of your oven, Seymour?
Oh, that isn't smoke, it's steam Steam from the steam clams
We're having, mmm, steam clams Mmm, steam clams Mmm, steam
clams Superintend, I hope you're ready for mouthwatering
hamburgers i thought we were having steamed clams don't know
i said steamed hams that's what i call hamburgers you call
hamburgers steamed ham yes it's a regional dialect uh-huh in
what region uh upstate new york really well i'm from utica
and i've never heard anyone use the phrase steamed hams oh
not in utica no it's an albany expression i see you know
these hamburgers are quite similar to the ones they have at
Krusty Burger.
Oh, no!
Patented Skinner Burger's old family recipe.
Four steamed hams.
Yes.
Yes, and you call them steamed hams, despite the fact
they're obviously grilled.
You know, one thing for...
Excuse me for one second.
Oh, okay.
Well, that was wonderful.
A good time was had by, oh, I'm pooped.
I should.
Good Lord, what is happening there?
Aurora Borealis.
Aurora Borealis, at this time of the year, at this time of
the day, in this part of the country, localized entirely
within your kitchen.
May I see it?
No.
Seymour, the house is on fire.
No, mother, it's just the northern lights.
Well, Seymour, you're an odd fellow.
But I must say, you seem a good ham.
Help!
No!
You did it!
You said I did it!
I served Steve now!
Absolutely, you know what?
I can't watch it again.
It's so hard.
This one Was hard because there's like There's no lot You
could tell I get cut off because there's no Like pauses I
can do I have to like match Like I That's crazy how I
matched the flash really well too Like
At first thank you with a super chat Thank you thank you
Kenem Same with a super chat Thank you Absolutely legendary
Boom Thank you with a super chat Thank you Thank you, Steve.
I'm a joke, you're weird.
Voices are all the characters.
I should have voiced, uh...
Well, Seymour, I made it.
Despite your directions.
Ah, Superintendent Chalmers, welcome.
I hope you're prepared for an unforgettable luncheon.
Meh.
Oh, you guys!
My roast is ruined!
But what if...
I worked at a precious fast food and skies as my own
cooking.
Oh, delightfully devilish, Seymour.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh.
Seymour!
Superintendent, I was just, I was just stretching my calves
on the way.
windowsill isometric exercise care to join me why is there
smoke coming out of your oven seymour um oh that isn't smoke
it's steam steam from the steam clams we're having mmm steam
clams steam clams super intent to help you're ready for
mouth-watering hamburgers i thought we were having steamed
clams don't know i said steamed hams that's what i call
hamburgers you call steamed hams?
Yes, it's a regional dialect.
Uh-huh.
In what region?
Uh, upstate New York?
Really?
Well, I'm from Utica, and I've never heard anyone use the
phrase steamed hams.
Oh, not in Utica.
No, it's an Albany expression.
I see.
You know, these hamburgers are quite similar to the ones
they have at Krusty Burger.
Oh, no!
Patent, it's Skinner Burger's old family recipe.
Four steamed hams.
Yes.
Yes, and you call them seam hams, despite the fact they're
obviously grilled.
You know, one thing for...
Excuse me for one second.
Oh, of course.
Ah, well, that was wonderful.
A good time was had by, oh, I'm pooped.
Yes, I should...
Good lord, what is happening there?
Aurora Borealis.
Aurora Borealis, at this time of the year, at this time of
the day, part of the country localized entirely within your
kitchen yes may i see it no seymour the ass is on fire no
mother is just the norton lights well seymour you're an odd
fellow by my say you seem a good ham
No!
It's too good.
I was too good.
They're too close to the sun.
I
don't know if I can eat this.
Oh my god.
I was too good at my job.
Guys, I'm fucked up.